bonjour à tous chaque samedi la voix est
libre sur france 3 alors que le salon de
l'agriculture ouvre ses portes à paris
sur fond de crise nous allons nous poser
la question pourquoi nos éleveurs
estiment utile en danger le secteur at
il condamné à vivre sous forme de
subventions après un an d'action parfois
musclées prenons le temps de voir
pourquoi nous en sommes arrivés là
nous sommes tous consommateurs dont tous
concernés nous qui recherchons au
quotidien la meilleure alimentation tout
en maîtrisant notre budget nous invité
ce matin d'abord se mêlent le grand
bonjour vous êtes président des jeunes
agriculteurs de bourgogne exploitants
vous même dans l'yonne à charbuy
christian decerle vous êtes éleveurs
enseigner loi bonjour nouvellement nommé
à la tête de la chambre d'agriculture de
bourgogne franche comté et membre de la
fdsea
françois patriat bonjour faucheurs
socialiste de la côte-d'or connaisseur
des questions agricoles en tant qu'ex
président du conseil régional elle était
ministre de l'agriculture en 2002 sous
lionel jospin et puis et vétérinaire de
formation et puis rémy et de lattes
bonjour pourront débuter les
républicains de la côte d'or est
propriétaire-exploitant vous connaissez
vos si bien l'agriculture
commençons par l'image de cette matinée
l'inauguration du salon de l'agriculture
par le président françois hollande si je
suis là aujourd'hui c'est pour montrer
qu'il ya une solidarité nationale at il
déclaré vous le voyez face à des
agriculteurs remontée estimant que
personne ne les écoute depuis un an
quelques insultes et mots fleuris à son
passage le stand du ministère de
l'agriculture a été démonté ce matin par
des manifestants
le diagnostic d'abord christian decerle
d'où vient cette crise de confiance
vis-à-vis de nos dirigeants
je crois que les agriculteurs souffrent
de trois choses au moins deux trois
choses une absence de revenus pour la
plupart que personne ne conteste et en
même temps dans presque toutes les
productions hors peut-être secteur
viticole
je pense que ce milieu souffre également
d'une complexité administrative qui a
pris de plus en plus de place dans
l'exercice de notre métier
et enfin j'aime bien cette formule les
paysans ont autant besoin de
considération que de revenus et je crois
que c'est merci nous inviter ici pour
débattre de l'agriculture et de la
situation difficile je pense lui a quand
même de très nombreuses émissions
télévisées de l'arctique qui blessent
des agriculteurs part peut-être une
critique souvent un feu nourri
et quand même quelque part un peu
excessive et injuste qui blessent des
agriculteurs donc voilà je pense que
derrière leurs revenus
le monde agricole aspire à retrouver
désespère des perspectives et je pense
qu'on peut en offrir voir si vraiment un
désamour sa balle le grand pourquoi les
agriculteurs subissent plus les
difficultés économiques dans ce contexte
que tous les autres secteurs finalement
en crise en ce moment la politique du
moins cher n'est pas forcément la
volonté française et il va falloir
aujourd'hui que le consommateur afin que
son agriculture reste puisse payer
aujourd'hui
un agriculteur un coût de production
donc on peut faire des efforts il ya
encore des marges de projet de progrès
mais est un moment il faut qu'on paye on
est dans un marché mondial on a une
agriculture qu on veut défendre et c'est
aujourd'hui cette cette problématique du
coût qui pèsent sur nos exploitations
françois patriat ce salon la nullité
cette année et sert à quelque chose
moi je me pose la question d'y
participer dans le contexte qu'on
connaît aujourd'hui parce qu'on va
rester sur les slogans et est ce qu'il
va en sortir des solutions
je rappelle que la crise agricole
aujourd'hui elle est mondiale elle a des
responsabilités multiples elle n'a pas
de réponse unique ni de slogan mondiale
parce que les cours sont mondiaux parce
que la crise avec la russie existe
européenne parce que l'europe n'a pas
d'unité autour de son modèle agricole
franco française à cause des politiques
nous sommes mis en cause le temps
consommateurs consommateurs qui
aujourd'hui entre l'aspiration avoir des
agriculteurs autour d'eux qu'ils
puissent gagner leur vie et payer le
prix du produit pas décidé non plus et
enfin le monde agricole lui-même monde
agricole de même qu'ils portent aussi sa
part de responsabilité parce qu'au
moment où on avoue on pense que la
solution c'est la régulation que nous le
sommes toujours battus pour avoir une
régulation des marchés souvent le monde
agricole est opposée à la régulation
s'est opposée lorsqu on a fait ce qu'on
a voulu mettre en place les quotas
laitiers ici et opposants quand on a
voulu réformer la pop en 93 je comprends
qu'il le mans aujourd'hui c'est parce
qu'ils voulaient un époque il croit
qu'il s'est trompé de chemin en disant
il faut laisser les agriculteurs
produire le monde a le droit de produire
sans s'apercevoir qu'au bout il fallait
vent et puis responsabilité aussi du
système commercial dans notre pays avec
une concentration des grandes surfaces
entre quatre grands groupes qui font la
pluie et le beau temps
alors que le monde agricole si tu lui a
échappé depuis les années 70 c'est la
plus-value
il n'est pas il n'a pas aujourd'hui la
maîtrise de la plus value de son produit
c'est vous dire le nombre de questions
qui lie à résoudre il sait pas par un
seul slogan en parlant d' de pansements
et terra aujourd'hui qu'on va régler le
problème il faut je crois que au niveau
national européen et mondial dans toutes
les instances on puisse mettre en place
des systèmes qui permettent à chaque
agriculture protéiforme et multiples
selon les continents et les pays d'avoir
un modèle qui soit viable quel est votre
sentiment qu'on voit ces images de
françois hollande
bousculé la colère des agriculteurs de
la connais depuis que je suis élu on a
connu des crises multiples aujourd'hui
le problème pourquoi sont ils autant
colère ce parce qu'ils ne voient pas
d'issue icompta décrit sur les prix on a
les prix sur les charges on a des
problèmes sanitaires avec l'accès aux
avec la grippe aviaire avec la
tuberculose et qu'on a des problèmes
dans le même temps européen des
problèmes d'exportation lisait notamment
avec la russie aujourd'hui et ce qui
nous pend au dessus la tête c'est
d'accord avec les américains qui vont
encore dire en difficulté à laquelle que
forza d'envoyer répondre en 3 mai à tout
cela c'est difficile ça les incite à
vrai travail ça fait beaucoup de choses
à leur convenance sur la chronologie
s'est passé des choses effectivement en
1 en février 2015
manifestation contre la nouvelle pac
c'était à mâcon il y a eu des blocages
d'abattoirs à cuiseaux à venarey il ya
eu la nuit de la détresse son mode
juillet à 9 heures à charolles à autun
il y eu la visite de françois hollande a
dit jouan mois de juillet pour essayer
de calmer tout ça il y a
également des réunions préfecture létard
est intervenu aussi pour recenser les
agriculteurs en grande difficulté il ya
une manifestation à paris en septembre
il y eu la crise la fièvre catarrhale la
venue de stéphane le foll à la foire de
dijon là aussi pour calmer le jeu et
puis la reprise des manifestations ce
dernier mois avallon ou encore à beaune
rémi delattre la solution elle vient du
monde politique
assurément assurément je crois que les
agriculteurs aujourd'hui sont dans une
situation de détresse que beaucoup
n'avaient pas complètement imaginé et
c'est essentiellement dû effectivement à
une conjoncture qui est difficile de
l'été des déprise agricole des décharges
beaucoup trop élevé sur nous nos
exploitations
et puis aussi une situation
conjoncturelle structurelle pardo qui
nécessite de grandes décisions
et là on a probablement trop tarder on
est aujourd'hui dans un contexte
européen c'est la politique agricole
commune qui réoriente qui organise la
profession et aujourd'hui on sent bien
que la france perd pied au niveau
européen
savez vous que il n'y a plus de français
autour du de la commission autour du
commissaire à l'agriculture c'est un
signe qui est tout à fait dramatique
on voit bien que le ministre de
l'agriculture n'est pas assez présent
n'est pas assez influent au niveau
européen moi je vais vous dire il ya eu
un signe d'ailleurs qui est tout à fait
dommageable pour la profession agricole
sa a été le remaniement ministériel
monsieur phal en grande difficulté par
rapport à la profession qui est
reconduit ministre et qui plus est qui
reste le porte parole du gouvernement
ça veut dire qu on a finalement un
ministre à temps partiel alors qu'on a
besoin de peser beaucoup plus lourd
aujourd'hui au niveau de bruxelles
deuxième signe qui a été tout à fait
dommageable pour la profession c'est de
nommer des ministres écologique écolo
comme on dit
vraiment ça c'est un signe tout à fait
néfaste pour la profession pourquoi
parce qu'aujourd'hui le paysan il
souffre d'énormes et souffrent de toutes
les contraintes qu'on lui a qu'on lui
impose au plan européen c'est sûr mais
aussi au plan national où on arrive
souvent sur sûr transposer les
directives européennes
je pense aux établissements dont
classées pour l'environnement
je pense aux directive nitrates qui sont
tout à fait dommageable pour la
profession et aujourd'hui il faut au
contraire qu' on rentre dans un système
où les contraintes pour l'exploitation
soit les moins fortes possibles et les
chargent également qu'ils sont par
rapport aux autres pays européens
beaucoup plus lourdes en france que dans
les autres pays membres de l'union
européenne
alors vous évoquez le personnage de
stéphane le foll il a droit à une visite
le week-end dernier surprise deux
agriculteurs en pleine nuit il ya eu un
anniversaire mouvementée également à
bourg en bresse il ya pas si longtemps
que ça ou des agriculteurs sont venus et
se sont déshabillés devant lui pour
expliquer qu'ils étaient mis à nu par
ses difficultés des actions menées
parfois par les jeunes agriculteurs
ça me legrand vous estimez qu'il n'y a
plus de pilote dans l'avion n'a plus
d'interlocuteur au ministère on n'est
pas là pour couper les têtes mais oui
l'ensemble du réseau jeunes agriculteurs
pensent que monsieur le foll n'a pu le
le laura qui devrait avoir sur le monde
agricole et échanger changer de ministre
aurait peut-être pu renouer le dialogue
au-delà de la question de monsieur le
foll il ya une question politique aussi
à avoir et de continuité politique
aujourd'hui le désastre qui se passe
aujourd'hui n'est pas de d'hier n'est
pas d'il ya trois ans il dure depuis des
années et des politiques de gauche de
droite qui arrive et qui disent qu'ils
étaient avant l'art est je fais autre
chose
la tva sociale sarkozy avait fait la tva
sociale
c'était ça aurait pu être un petit bol
d'air pour l'agriculture à l'export à
l'import et défendre un peu notre
territoire dans une europe où on veut de
l'europe
ça a été décrit par monsieur hollande
qui deux ans après dit j'aurais
peut-être pas dû le faire
voilà
gauche la droite il ya des choses bien
dans les deux côtés il faut arriver à ce
qu'on ait une continuité politique afin
de garder une agriculture en france et
afin d'éviter si un drame pour moi la
montée des extrêmes christian decerle
vous avez un poids à jouer la chambre
d'agriculture c'est une instance
importante également faste exemple en
tout cas ce qui me réjouit autour de
cette table c'est qu'on partage ensemble
que c'est un sujet qui ne laisse
personne indifférent je pense que le
dernier sondage viennent nous rappeler
que les français aiment leurs
agriculteurs et se soucient de leur
devenir
donc c'est déjà me semble-t-il un atout
ensuite on dirait qu'on redécouvre que
l'agriculture est une économie comme une
autre c'est assez surréaliste
c'est même une économie assez fine assez
pointu qui demande beaucoup de
performances de capacité d'adaptation de
la part des agriculteurs
on a quand même hissé en une
cinquantaine d'années ce pays de la
france des tickets de pain ça date un
peu mais c'est pas si lointain à une des
toutes premières puissances
exportatrices
ce qui prouve quand même le potentiel du
monde paysan de son organisation quand
il passe un deal avec le monde politique
à relever les défis aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui je pense qu'il faut
comprendre que les agriculteurs ne
peuvent pas vendre en dessous de leurs
coûts de production
voilà et qu'à partir de ce moment-là il
appartient une volonté politique
affirmée mais aussi des différents
opérateurs qui jouent un rôle
déterminant dans l'organisation de ce
secteur de redonner du revenu aux
agriculteurs points autrement les
agriculteurs disparaîtront et sans
dramatiser on a perdu le quart des
actifs agricoles dans les dix dernières
années aujourd'hui on est arrivé à un
niveau en dessous du en dessous duquel
descende encore serait dangereux parce
qu'au delà de la perte d'actifs
agricoles
c'est l'amour et laval et tout l'emploi
qui va autour qui poserait un grave
problème
donc oui le réseau consulaire à une
double mission celle d'accompagner la
montée en puissance permanente de la
professionnalisation technico-économique
dans les exploitations
parce qu'on a encore des marges de
progrès d'accompagner une organisation
collective du monde agricole
par son implication dans ces filières
est probablement passé passé au niveau
des régions au niveau national des deals
avec certes la puissance publique mais
aussi les opérateurs économiques et les
distributeurs
mais je pense que les consommateurs ne
peuvent pas être à la fois attachée à
leur agriculture et rêver à un modèle
décalée de la réalité économique
avant d'évoquer ce problème de la grande
distribution françois patriat ses fans
de x l'était toujours à sa place
aujourd'hui
alors j'aime bien aimé la tout cela plus
j'apprécie parce que c'est quelqu'un qui
a la femme modéré qui réfléchit mais il
nous entraîne dans un débat où je t'ai
parlé de ma g penser aujourd'hui que
répondent aux agriculteurs qui demandent
des prix rémunérateurs que la solution
passe par le changement d'un ministre
qui par ailleurs connaît très bien les
problèmes agricoles
il ya consacré toute sa vie ses
informations personnelles connaît les
dossiers qui se bat bruxelles avec une
intensité que je le remarque et ça me
paraît un peu facile je le dire un arrêt
nient les charges
on va voir on parle des charges trop tôt
par des charges en agriculture détente
elle du gouvernement qu'est-ce qui
dépend comme charge du gouvernement le
foncier bâti 15 9 bat il y en a plus les
charges sociales
on vient de les baisser de 10% pour le
reste les charges les intrants les
charges le matériel le vétérinaire les
insecticides l'étranger tout ça c'est
pas le gouvernement
c'est pas le gouvernement c'est des
produits les normes je viens au nord les
non la france ne surent transpose pas
s'éteindre elle est en retard elle se
sait condamné le risque demain pour
répondre aux consommateurs que régnier
de mode aux consommateurs est-ce qu'il
faut mois denis trappe plus de nitrates
et plus de pesticides insecticides
vous allez voir ce que le contenu des
consommateurs vont vous répondre la
solution elle n'est pas là aujourd'hui
c'est pas une solution
seulement politique est pensé que ce
serait le quinquennat de françois
hollande qui sera responsable de tous
les maux voit bien qu'ils en arrière le
nombre d'agriculteurs je réponds à
christian j'apprécie aussi beaucoup
moi je me souviens tu débat en 93 y
avait un million cent mille agriculteurs
j'avais dit un jour il y en aura plus
que 500 milles je me suis fait hué et
chahuté au concours de saulieu
aujourd'hui il ya 6 500 mille
agriculteurs ont produit plus et on
produit mieux quand 93 aujourd'hui en
france donc c'est pas un problème
d'actifs d'exploitation s'appelle
d'actifs agricoles globale il faut
aujourd'hui l'agriculture créé des
emplois en amont et en aval et dans
l'exploitation ne le pensons pas en
termes de ferme aujourd'hui d'envoyer
qu'on sorte un petit peu des clichés
pour aller un peu plus loin pour trouver
des solutions alors sur ces chiffres le
nombre d'exploitations malgré toi
diminué en un peu plus de 40 ans en 1970
on comptait 60 2006 en exploitation dans
la région bourgogne en 2007 tombé à 26
1400 on est à dix neuf mille neuf cent
pour les chiffres de 2013 ça veut dire
qu'on a perdu deux tiers en nombre
d'exploitations d'où vient cette baisse
spectaculaire
il ya une rupture est qu une
restructuration qui doit se faire nouchi
jeunes agriculteurs on veut défendre
l'installation est encore de la place
après pour mettre aujourd'hui des
agriculteurs à la place d'autres il faut
alors nous redonner de l'ambition
quand vous voulez développer une
entreprise parce qu'aujourd'hui on est
dans le développement
il faut qu'on ait des chambres
consulaires qu'ils soient derrière nous
il faut qu'on ait des politiques qu'ils
soient derrière nous et socialement il
faut que les gens acceptent le
développement des exploitations
quand on a des projets d'élevage je
viens de l'yonne quand des bâtiments
d'élevage m 2 à 3 ans à sortir de terre
pour 50 70 80 vaches on n'est pas sur
les mille vaches
il ya un moment il faut que
l'agriculteur il a envie il veut faire
le jeune il veut faire mais faut lui
donner les moyens et rapidement un autre
habitant à la campagne
invité dans un village la tâche revient
vers ses avantages ses ces contraintes
la campagne a ses avantages ses
contraintes
on est là il faut qu'on vive ensemble et
aujourd'hui un exploitant agricole qui
veut développer l'agro écologie qui
tient chaud fort un autre mini stéphane
le foll celle équilibre entre l'élevage
et la céréaliculture
aujourd'hui la politique qu'on a fait
détruire l'élevage il faut que l'agro
écologie défendre l'élevage et qu'on ait
une rentabilité sur nos exploitations et
on installera des jeunes en
développement les exploitations par
l'élevage par le photovoltaïque par la
méthanisation
mais il faut qu'on arrête d'avoir une
société qui se met au travers de tous
les développements pour compliqué
aujourd'hui de monter une exploitation
et donc d'obtenir des autorisations
demande aujourd'hui un jeune exploitant
et la défendent d'avoir un niveau de
formation très élevé cbs plus que btac
beaucoup couru de formation cette
semaine sur les com a travaillé à la
région alors il faut installer des
jeunes et dans quelles conditions et
surtout pour quelle rentabilité
le problème aujourd'hui c'est la
rentabilité est installé un agriculteur
pour qui ça va demander des des
centaines de milliers d'euros de
capitaux pour avoir demain 60 vaches
allaitantes ne pas vivre demain
est ce que c'est une bonne solution
est-ce qu'on peut le faire comme tel
donc je crois que c'est le modèle
agricole
pensé par le gouvernement de l'époque et
parler syndicalisme agricole est révolu
il faut trouver aujourd'hui un modèle
agricole qui soit rentable ne pas
condamner la ou autre de ses modèles
le modèle productiviste à six raisons et
il est capable aujourd'hui d'aller dans
l'export de fournir des produits à bas
coûts le modèle traditionnel français
adapté à sa géographie à son terrenoir
au sahara soit l'adversaire il a aussi
ses raisons et je voudrais donner une
dernière réponse d'un réel talent sur
deux pages donne raison sur d'autres
mains
c'est vrai que le remaniement
gouvernemental moi je je pense que
stéphane a eu raison de rester je pense
que l'arrivée des écologistes elle est
là pour des raisons politiques que
chacun partage qu'on peut approuver mais
ils n'auront pas de poids sur le
gouvernement entende tel d'ailleurs sont
ils vraiment écologistes à la matière je
veux pas débattre sur ce sujet là
aujourd'hui mais je reviens en arrière
c'est des cons stéphane le foll et
j'étais en désaccord avec lui et je suis
toujours en désaccord avec lui à défaut
nu a défendu les 52 premiers hectares
pour le financement de la pac disant
voilà 52 on va mais il a répondu en cela
à ses agriculteurs ali les bretons les
gens du pays de loire qui disent
aujourd'hui nous ne turf ac 45 ha
défendez nous au moins je proteste
en dix ans cinquante deux hectares en
bourgogne dans l'yonne ont ça ne veut
rien dire
c'est une c'est en ce sens pas une très
bonne réforme donc je croyais il a
défendu le modèle agricole breton de
l'ouest qui petit exploitation au top et
ça ne fonctionne pas aujourd'hui mais le
grand le problème des 50 premiers
hectares c'est autre chose
après il faut savoir ce qu'on veut si on
veut un tissu rural si on veut des
paysans si on veut des jeunes
s'installent
je suis d'accord avec vous il faut
réorganiser les filières faut réinvestir
les flir c'est aux jeunes aussi de
réintégrer l'école les conseils
d'administration des coopératives
aujourd'hui et il faut dialoguer on a
peut-être un point de rupture avec les
transformateurs et la grande
distribution de c'est à nous de se
réapproprier ce dialogue la grande
distribution les transformateurs les
politiques mais il faut qu'on se donne
un cap et qu'on a tous dans le même sens
on ne peut pas aujourd'hui dire les 52
premiers hectares ça tu es la bourgogne
nous en bourgogne
on a aussi besoin de personne dans le
territoire et c'est pas 5000 euros les
50 de premiers hectares nous on est soit
300 ha je veux dire c'est 5000 euros
différents sur l'exploitation c'est
parce un minimum ses cinquante mille
quand votre prix de production veut te
votre prix varient de votre chiffre
d'affaires varie de 30 à 40 % d'une
année sur trois comment vous faites pour
avoir un cap
donc il faut ré ré intégrer des systèmes
qui vont ni serrer marché sur plusieurs
années peut-être qu'il faut un multi
fiscale quand on gagne de l'argent on
paye des impôts
on paye de la msa peut-être qu'il ya
quelque chose qu'il faudrait lycée pour
nous éviter d'investir
ça sert à rien non plus d'investir pour
défiscaliser voilà il ya il ya quelque
chose armes est on est au fond du
gouffre les jeunes agriculteurs
la fnsea a des propositions et il faut
qu'aujourd'hui on aille dans ce sens
dans le dialogue et dans la construction
une christian decerle sur ses modèles
d'exploitation on entend beaucoup parler
des grandes exploitations des fermes des
millevaches
par exemple c'est quelque chose auquel
et il faut s'opposer j'ai trouvé
françois patriat
pardonnons quand même un peu volontiers
le ministre bon je vais quand même
prendre à dire un mot je crois qu autour
de ce plateau quelles que soient les
sensibilités des uns des autres on est
tous d'accord que c'est pas dans les 18
derniers mois que ce qu'on trouve les
les racines de la crise agricole qu'elle
est plus ancienne et que malheureusement
les gouvernements successifs ont eu de
la peine à faire face à trouver des
réponses
ceci étant dit tous les jours ou presque
on entend dire que y'aura plus
d'habitants sur la planète dont plus de
besoins alimentaires et dans la sphère
c'est pas un jeu à somme nulle
pendant que la france l'agriculture
française a tendance à régresser et
s'enlise dans ces problèmes d'autres
pays y compris sur le territoire
européen gagne e à notre détriment des
parts de marché que nous nous perdons et
quelque part quand même ça nous renvoie
à la question de notre propre
responsabilité nationale en matière de
compétitivité de performance voilà il a
été question des écologistes moi je
crois que les paysans sont respectueux
de leur environnement
voilà ils ont répondu avec des produits
qui avait d autorisation de mise en
marché à des pratiques pour lesquels les
réseaux se déchirent mariculture mais
aussi ceux du ministère de l'agriculture
ont envoyé des messages et c'est que
aujourd'hui ils doivent qui à voir et
qui l'y a une inflexion de fait sur des
pratiques tant mieux on répond présent
ceci étant dit sur le sujet de l'
approche environnementale
on peut pas être dans le dogme et
quelque part quand ta profession
agricole demande désespérément qu'on
veuille bien faire quelques retenues
d'eau quelques retenues collinaires pour
pour pour constituer des réserves
l'hiver en période d'excédent et les
restituer l'été à du végétal qui en a
besoin et que ses demandes empreinte de
bon sens ne peuvent jamais aboutir il
faut aussi se poser la question de
pourquoi pays en arrive là donc on peut
pas aimer les paysans peut pas dire
qu'on les aime et chaque fois le
rattacher des boulets pour les
contraintes pendant d'autres gagnent du
terrain
je crois qu'il ya quelque chose de tout
à fait intéressant dans notre discussion
c'est de se dire finalement qu'est
l'agriculture on veut pour pour demain
quelles sont les missions que l'on
confie aux paysans de france et et
d'europe nourrir nos concitoyens on sera
de plus en plus nombreux et surtout le
consommateur il a aujourd'hui des
exigences en termes de qualité qui ont
nécessité que des paysans s'adapte dans
leur production et dans la
transformation et ça je dois dire que de
tout temps le paysan a été assez
extraordinaires sont de ce point de vue
puisqu'il a toujours eu cette capacité
de s'adapter
le deuxième le deuxième élément c'est de
se dire on a besoin aujourd'hui
d'assurer de la lisibilité pour les
jeunes en particulier ce qu'elle samuel
évoqué il ya un instant
aujourd'hui le jeune agriculteur c'est
un chef d'entreprise et aujourd'hui il
n'a pas du tout de visibilité c'est pas
finalement quel sera son avenir on
comprend aujourd'hui ya soixante dix
mille agriculteurs de moi en cinq ans en
france 70 villes ce qui est considérable
c'est 13% de la population agricole
donc il est il est important à la fois
qu'on puisse donner des gages à nos
agriculteurs les aider dans leurs
installations
mais leur assurer que demain ils auront
effectivement un avenir qui leur
permettra de vivre de leur métier et
pour ça il ya des outils à des leviers
effectivement qu'il faut mettre en
oeuvre il faut s'assurer que au niveau
des prix on puisse s'adapter on sait
bien que les prix agricoles sont très
volatils il faut qu'on ait donc des
moyens de pouvoir
règle enfin organiser les prix dans la
transparence dans la justice entre le
producteur le transformateur et le
distributeur et françois patriat les
régions tout à l'heure de rappeler que
le consommateur a toujours été habitué à
avoir un niveau de prix qui ne
correspond pas vraiment au coût de
revient du produit alimentaire et ça
c'est des choix politiques qui ont été
faits au niveau mondial c'est les
américains qui à l'origine on est et qui
ont été à l'origine de ces dispositions
aujourd'hui il faut faire avec mais il
ya une chose qui n'est pas acceptable
c'est que le paysan lui finalement
puisse vendre des produits en dessous du
coût de revient et donc il faut que dans
la définition du prix à la consommation
il ya une juste répartition juste
équilibre entre le producteur
transformateur et deuxième élément
important s'est il faut aider les
agriculteurs à investir et on sait bien
que il faudrait à peu près que
l'agriculture investissent 3 milliards
d'euros dans les temps qui viennent
aujourd'hui il n'en a pas les moyens
donc il faut qu'on puisse avoir des
leviers leviers fiscaux évoqué samuel
lien et un instant mais également qu'on
puisse adossés à des des financements de
l'agriculture par exemple sur ce qu'on
pourrait appeler un livret vert faire en
sorte que les pagnes populaires puissent
est ciblée vers l'agriculture
c'était d'ailleurs des dispositions qui
étaient dans une proposition de loi du
sénat je sais
françois que le groupe socialiste n'a
pas voté six dispositions mais en tout
cas une certaine tenue mais ce qui est
fâcheux c'est que ces dispositions qui
vont vraiment dans le bon sens pour la
profession ont été balayées d'un revers
de la main par la commission des
affaires économiques à l'assemblée
nationale ce qui fait qu on n'avance pas
sur sur ce sujet là et c'est vraiment un
des aspects tout à fait important et
troisième élément enfin c'est faire en
sorte que l'on simplifie effectivement
la vie de nos paysans et surtout qu'on
diminue les charges tu disais tout à
l'heure françois que le français non
bâti avait disparu de non non non c'est
les agriculteurs alors il est très bon
et des traversées n'y a rien et c'est la
diminuer de près c'est aussi le coût de
la main d'oeuvre est quelque chose de
tout à fait nécessaire on sait
qu'aujourd'hui le salaire minimum en
france 1400 le zéro quand il est de 700
en espagne pour prendre à ces chiffres
les revenus et la compétitivité
l'installation des jeunes agriculteurs
émission spéciale à l'occasion du salon
de l'agriculture en direct sur france 3
puis vos questions bien sûr également
sur france 3 point fr la discussion
continue en direct juste après le point
sur l'actualité à la mi journée